- [Kelly] That's yours.
(audience claps)
- This is mine.
- Look at that.
(audience claps)
- [Kelly] And it, I like how it,
I like how it hugs the back.
- You like how it hugs the back?
- I like how it hugs the back.
Because like that's the, I
got to show the waist off.
So I like that, yeah.
- [Idina] Yes, and on a good
day it can hug the back,
and on a bad day you can take the belt off
and just let it-
- Yeah
- not hug anything.
- Yeah and just let it
feel like a Snuggie, I love it.
- Yeah.
- It's nice to see you again.
- Great to see you-
- Yeah
- Hi.
- So I heard that you
recently made it back to "Wicked"
but you were watching it this time.
- Yes, I've never gone back to see-
one time I went back and my son was three,
and he was so rambunctious.
He kept hitting the backseat
of the people in front of me.
So I had to leave and I wrote a letter-
- And you're like "maybe too early."
- Yes. And I wrote a letter to the-
- Yeah.
- the women that were in it, apologizing
because you know, if
they heard that somebody-
have you, I mean if I left
in the middle of the show
they would think that I-
- Oh of course, of course, yeah.
- Yeah. So-
- That's happened to me before.
Something happened-
- That's what I'm say-
- in my family
and I had to leave a show
and then I guess it got
back to them that I left,
and I was like-
- [Idina] And then they
think you didn't like them-
- oh my God it had nothing to do with you.
- Exactly.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah. But I was there
with seven 12-year-old boys
who are all--my son and
his basketball team.
His coach is actually from the East Coast
and has been telling them that they
they're too West Coast.
They're too soft.
They have to meet all
of the New York kids.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- So they were scrimmaging.
I brought them all on a plane
and then I was like
where can I take them Saturday night
to a Broadway show?
Oh, "Wicked" will give me tickets.
And I took-
- Oh.
(audience laughs)
and they were riveted.
They just sat there the whole time,
they were just so into it.
They kind of-
some had seen "The Wizard of Oz"
some hadn't but it was just-
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- [Idina] Yeah, well-
- How do you miss that as a child?
- [Idina] I tried to show my son
but he just wanted to watch
dinosaurs or whatever.
- Oh my God. I didn't
even give mine the option.
I was like, wait, this part's real good.
- [Idina] But it's scary.
- [Kelly] It is a little scary.
- A little scary.
- Except my kids like
the scary characters.
Like my kids gravitate towards
the Ursulas-
- Well now he does.
- or the Gastons.
Yeah.
- He loves scary now for sure.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like he loved his
T-rexes--that kind of scary.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh my God,
my kids love dinosaurs, both of them.
- Yeah.
- Does your son think that
you're cool generally or not?
It's kind of hard.
- I think, yeah, you know,
he doesn't think I'm cool.
I'm like, like this.
Like I'm not allowed to say the word drip
drippy or whatever.
(audience laughs)
Because that's-
- What? What do you mean?
- that's his word.
He says things like,
"This is so drippy mom."
He's really into his fashion
and all his basketball-
- Is that like trippy
and dope in the same-
- [Idina] Kind of.
- Okay.
- So I'll say, he'll come
out ready for school,
and be like, whoa, that is so drippy.
And he'll be like, no.
You don't get to say
(Kelly laughs) the word.
- That's my vocabulary.
- Now I just said it
on national television.
He's gonna die.
(audience laughs)
- We're going to-
- Mom, how could you say drippy?
I said drippy. And then the other day, I
(Kelly laughs)
I was taking him, I was
going to pick him up
from school, and I was too lazy
to go up the stairs to
get my own sneakers,
and I'm finally in the
same size sneakers as him.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And so, or he's finally
in the same sneakers size-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- as me.
And I guess he had, I got him,
I spoiled him and I got him some
Yeezys for Christmas last year.
- Oh okay, yeah.
- And I was like, oh,
I've never tried these.
So I put them on and I went
and picked him up from school
and he comes out and he goes,
- [Kelly] Oh.
- "How could you wear those?"
(Kelly and audience laughs)
He said, "Without socks?
Do you know how expensive those are?"
I was like, yeah, that's why I thought
I could put them on
and go and pick you up from school.
- [Kelly] Because I bought them.
- Yes.
But, apparently those are very drippy.
- I love that he really
just didn't want you
sweating in them, like ruining them.
- My feet are so proud.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I changed your diaper,
but I can't put my feet in your sneakers.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I've wiped
your butt multiple times.
(Idina and audience laugh)
Build a bridge, get over it.